okay i heard this wild story that denzel
washington cold called bazlerman and
said
you're about to get this guy and watch
out for this guy when you hear that what
what goes through your head
i i oh yeah yeah take me off the hook
taking him off the hook help me answer
this question
all right yeah
all
right
i was just getting asked about when
denzel called
uh and i i honestly i've got this thing
right now where i just feel like
he's my hero you know i i ca i still
gotta i can't believe he knows my name
so the fact that he would call oh you
know i just feel so honored i don't even
know what to say it's denzel right she's
standing next to lise marie right now i
was about to say now listen
lisa marie you tweeted if this man does
not win an oscar for this role i will
eat my foot that's what you said i wish
i didn't i mean i mean it but i wish i
didn't say it i've been telling
everybody watching him play your fault
it did something to me it really did and
so what did it do to you oh a lot a lot
i wasn't ready for what i did i really
wasn't
bass kind of left me alone in the
theater the first time i saw it so i
kind of watched it by myself
embraced myself and when vaz came to get
me after the film i
just fell into him in tears just and i
could barely i couldn't speak he had to
like walk me in my car i was like you
know so we saw it again last night and
you know it's just i can't not
you want to keep watching it you want to
keep watching this one you told me when
we were in memphis that you know before
you had only sing for people that were
close to you but now that you've seen it
now that you've heard yourself does it
give you more confidence
[Music]
i need to get back to who i really am
i mean right now i'm just taking one
step at a time but i i really it's that
you know when when you're getting to
[Music]
not be yourself you know
and uh
walking out there and feeling like i'm
looking out of his eyes it's the most
empowering feeling that one can feel so
i got the gift of experiencing that and
feeling a rapport with the audience in
the way that i did so it was just an
incredible gift to me i i don't know
what the future holds but
uh i just i just rest in the fact that
that was the time of my life elise
murray um finally you know just having
three generations of presley women here
today to experience this your legacy and
paying honor to your father what does
that mean to you it means everything to
us it's so important i mean everything
that's happening right now it's so
important the movie is important the
subject matter is important the stories
that it tells the history that it gives
it's all very important it's very
relevant right now it's important in our
society it's important in our culture
and i feel like and and historically
this is obviously a huge honor to me and
my family and
and my children to be asked to do this
and
just to have all this happening right
now i just think that this is the most
important time that this could be
happening it's not just because it's my
father and it covers a lot of ground
that needs to be covered and issues
exactly i feel the same way and i think
we talked about a lot of that will his
spirit ever leave you because when i was
listening to you today i was like
there's that voice is there baby it's
still there i hope not yeah i hope not
so before i i had the honor to
betray elvis in this film i was a i was
a fan of course but
i also felt a very
soulful connection to him one that i i
couldn't quite explain
and
thanks to baz who gave me the gift of
this role
my understanding of elvis as
a
artist
as a
global pop culture icon
as a historic figure
and
most importantly as a human being
has has grown beyond uh what i
could have ever imagined there's a lot
of people saying a lot of things
but in the end you gotta listen to
yourself
and with it my respect for his legacy
the legacy he left behind and his loved
ones who have carried it forward
i think it's safe to say that elvis
would be so proud
to
see the loves of his life
his family
here today to honor him along with all
of you
[Music]
you